qué significa es el primer acuerdo en
materia diplomática
buenas tardes es un paso adelante es
bien importante no solamente
diplomático y político para el reino
unido- para el primer ministro boris
johnson sino para ustedes raúl para mí
para toda la humanidad es un paso bien
importante y es el primer gran acuerdo
el primer gran avance de esta con 26 de
glasgow que ha sido considerado un punto
de inflexión para salvar el planeta es
bien importante
mencionar que tener a brasilia china en
un mismo mismo acuerdo significa una
transformación porque primero porque la
china es considerado el gran emisor de
efectos de gases invernaderos y porque
además por toda la producción de soya
por las importaciones se ha aumentado la
deforestación en ese país pero también
por brasilia lo escuchábamos el
presidente para ya ir bold sonar una
figura polémica alrededor de todos estos
asuntos ha afirmado hoy su compromiso
pero también brasil porque es
considerado el gran pulmón del planeta
esto por la región de la amazonía se
considera que la deforestación en brasil
ha aumentado al nivel más alto desde el
2018 con 11 mil kilómetros cuadrados de
árboles destruidos entre agosto de 2019
y julio de 2020 por eso podemos entender
la dimensión la importancia de este
acuerdo que insisto no sólo es político
y diplomático sino sobre todo que sirve
para usted para mí para todos para la
humanidad para salvar nuestro planeta
también el primer ministro boris johnson
ha existido ha pedido conservar los
bosques salvarlos y ha dicho que si
sembrar un árbol es importante pero no
solamente como un acto personal sino por
la importancia de crear un balance y un
equilibrio para la naturaleza como lo
decían también ayer luisa es una lucha
de todos porque al final todos aquí
vivimos y es que américa latina también
está planteando al mundo que tiene los
ecosistemas pero que necesita apoyo y
dinero para así poder protegerlos luís a
[Música]
sin duda aquí raúl en esta con 26 en
glasgow los países latinoamericanos que
han asistido son pocos en realidad hay
que decirlo están reclamando el nivel
fundamental el lugar importante que
tiene américa latina' en todo este
esfuerzo común de salvar el planeta
hemos escuchado de los discursos del
presidente de argentina de ecuador y de
colombia a eso tenemos gran parte de los
ecosistemas únicos especies que no se
encuentran en ningún otro rincón del
planeta en nuestra región debemos
salvarlos debemos encontrar el apoyo de
estos países desarrollados que con todos
los recursos la tecnología pueden
contribuir para que entonces puedan
mantenerse como los grandes pulmones del
planeta porque recordemos no son grandes
emisores de gases de efecto invernadero
pero tienen lo que todos requerimos y
son los árboles y toda esta
infraestructura toda esta vegetación
todos estos ecosistemas únicos que todos
debemos salvar es así entonces como
américa latina' llega reclamando de una
u otra manera
y ese papel fundamental en todo este
propósito de cada una de las personas
que se encuentra aquí de salvar el
planeta